hello folks
welcome to
rational science directly from the
ukraine i mean from germany
frankfurt germany no you don't want to
be in ukraine at this moment in time bad
time to be there
no no vacations over there
anyways we're going to be dealing with
something called gravity
what in the world is gravity
that's what we're going to be talking
about today
so if you've got something better to do
don't do it stick around you might learn
something
anyways let's get on with this subject
of the ukraine war what's going on over
there well as i've said for the past a
couple weeks
uh
this is a war that's got relatively
little to do with ukraine i mean it's
got to do something with ukraine
obviously
but this is a war
uh of the us united states against
germany that's what it's all about okay
the united states has for several months
now
been trying to get uh germany to cancel
um
this nordstrom 2 pipeline which was
going to uh provide germany with
cheaper gas directly from
the
from russia
and uh
the person who's in charge of that is uh
schroeder who used to be the chancellor
of germany
so
you can imagine if this guy is up there
you know and he's
a friend of the the current president uh
chancellor of uh germany
uh
you know and had a good chance of
you know
being turned on
at least they were calculated by june of
this year well the united states wanted
to stop that at all costs that was one
of the main reasons you know uh that
this went on uh this war
started
and uh
republicans and the democrats both in
the united states
uh wanted to stop the pipeline but they
couldn't go to germany and force them
and say look you got to stop that
pipeline because you're going to be in
the hands of the russians and so on and
uh merkel was still chancellor of
germany at the time and she said well
you know this
like this is a problem between germany
and uh in russia uh the us has little to
say here
and united states
put the pressure but had nothing to put
the pressure with
until we get to the war with ukraine now
there is
uh
some political pressure there that
germany cannot avoid
and lots of things have changed this
week and here are all the headlines it
gives you an idea why this is a war
against germany not against russia okay
primarily against uh oh sorry got the
wrong one
where is it
here it is these are the headlines us
declares russia's prize north stream two
pipeline dead
it's a good thing uh you know it's the
us who declares it dead not germans or
or russians
the us declared it dead then the uh they
have this swift system which is uh what
um
helps or what facilitates uh
transactions between russia and europe
in general
uh for payments
and united states wanted to stop that as
well and the only
country opposing it was germany in fact
as of this moment they still haven't
taken a decision but in the next couple
days they probably will
and what that will do is cut funds all
together to russia and so uh but the
problem is it hurts germany as well
because germany has lots of dealings
with russia up to this point and united
states wanted to stop that then it says
germany makes historic shift on weapons
to ship
ukraine arms in other words germany was
not shipping arms to ukraine they were
shipping uh you know health things like
you know things for hospitals and so on
uh
maybe uh um what is it uniforms and
things of that nature and now they're
gonna ship arms and then uh they're
going to invest 113 billion on defense
now the united states for years has
asked germany to increase
its defense budget and germany refused
germany was using that money to make
itself richer by
improving its uh economy and
stimulating its business
and now it's going to dedicate 113
billion on defense
so you can see all the changes that
happened just this week for germany
alone
and i think this uh
this was a result of
uh tremendous pressure by the by the
united states against germany and with
the attack on ukraine it's like what are
we gonna say no
so they had to fall in line and so
what's happening here is uh
the united states is playing good
politics here i i think uh in other
words
uh here they forced
the russians to attack ukraine why
because ukraine said it might join nato
meaning that it could allow missiles
with nuclear warheads
in ukrainian territory
and so the russians said oh no you don't
no we don't want missiles
of that nature
uh on our southern border there
and so that's part of the reason they
attacked ukraine the other one is a you
know they wanted to join nato and and
that means that that would automatically
trigger a defense a mutual defense pact
okay so there were lots of reasons for
russia to be worried about that because
uh the united states is
slowly uh the empire's expanding closer
and closer to moscow
and so the russians didn't like that at
all so here it's good politics on the
side of the united states because
without shooting a single bullet
okay without losing a single soldier
it creates a war for russia
against whom
against russians here you have ruski's
killing russkies because the ukrainians
are russians there's no difference
between them they speak
practically the same language they all
speak russian
they have the same religion orthodox
they have the same culture
in fact
music is very similar
the reason lots of people in moscow
protested is because the way they see
this war is that russia is attacking
their brothers
what do you mean you're attacking this
province
of the ex-soviet union yeah you're
killing our own people our own brothers
and so here
you have russians killing russians
essentially and the united states is
just eating popcorn on the sidelines and
laughing and they did it without firing
a single shot and meanwhile they get to
keep germany and france
which now have to cut their ties to
russia and probably soon
uh with china
and so you can see where this is going
the united states empire is expanding
at the expense first of germany and
france the expense of europe and uh
eventually you know it's going to meet
up with the russian empire
and the chinese empire in the east
and we'll see what happens then
so it's getting uh gonna be a great uh
next few years there you know whatever
happens
but that's what i think is going on
and one fellow says
he says uh the psychopath politicians
and their sock puppet press are
threatening sanctions on russia in their
or else threats germany shut all their
nuclear power stations and are massively
dependent on russian gas
if they stop buying the gas the whole eu
will go bankrupt
yeah one of the problems here is that
the
germans here depend lots on
russian gas
and the united states says hey uh we'll
sell you the gas from now on how's that
uh it'll be a little more expensive you
know we're gonna uh you know export it
by the teaspoons to germany and you're
going to have to pay for it
and but they want to cut the dependence
of europe on russian gas they don't like
that at all they're americans
and
it's so crazy because the germans uh
shut down uh are shutting down are in
the process of shutting down their last
couple of uh power plants one down here
a few miles from where i live in worms
which is by the way uh where uh martin
luther was tried
what was it uh
1521 i think uh by charles v and his
court you know they tried him for
blasphemy
and um in worms they had two power
plants
and
biblos one and bibles two
and i went down there to see it and yeah
they were
to be shut in 21 or 22 so right now
they've they shut them down i think the
other day
finally so germany shut down the power
plants why because people here they said
look we don't want the danger
you know power plants especially after
chernobyl uh they said we don't want
this happening here and so they shut
down the power plants
but
it's uh i don't know if people are aware
but see this this is what's going on the
united states has nukes
here in germany you know and this is the
map and you can see germany has nukes uh
that are controlled by the united states
and so
so on the one hand they shut down their
power plants on the other they have all
these nukes inside their uh
country
and you see that region there known as
kalinin and that i marked in red there
that's russian territory and it's on the
other side of a couple countries that
are in the way uh the uh those baltic
nations like lithuania and estonia and
so on
and
right now they shut down the airspace
russians cannot travel now through the
airspace directly to kalining they have
to go around if they want to get to
kalining
and
so what the russians did i think was now
in 2016 they started putting
missiles with nukes
in kalinin and those missiles will be
headed towards germany
so we have on the one hand germans are
accepting nukes from the united states
and the russians saying okay no problem
you accept nukes from the states we're
going to put nukes and kalinin and shoot
them at you
because you accepted nukes in your
country
so it's it's so weird because on the one
hand the russians uh the public right uh
they said it's a danger to have all
these nuclear power plants and here they
have the nukes
that the americans are putting here so
and it's going to get a lot it's got to
be a lot of fun because now the russians
threaten with uh stopping the start
uh treaty
they're prolonging it from what for five
more years and
which is the agreement where they limit
the number of nukes that each side has
and they have to be able to verify each
other and right now the russians are
threatening with pulling out of that and
saying we're not going to have you
visit our country and checking out how
many nukes we have
and so it's going to be a lot of fun in
the next few days
years i mean if if we leave months is
better
we can't guarantee years yet
okay
what all these countries are doing now
especially the big guys china russia and
the united states they're mutually
you know
using sanctions against each other the
united states is sanctioning uh
china and china does the same to the
united states the other day here we had
beijing
uh they sanctioned
lockheed and raytheon to uh companies
that
uh
make weapons and they
sell these weapons to taiwan and china
doesn't like that so they said we're
gonna punish you you know
and
then you see at the bottom that the
investors are a lot worried about this
um these sanctions that these countries
are putting on each other especially now
with the ukraine war all the sanctions
that are going to be applied to russia
and russia is going to pay in kind to
companies that uh have their businesses
in russia
so
it's going to be mutual and china is
probably going to
punish a few american companies and vice
versa
so it's got to be great because
everybody's now sanctioning everybody
else and that's not good for business
for anybody believe me
so but that's where all these people are
headed and here you have
the
you know the economic risks that
can happen because of all these
sanctions
and
one of the things that came out is that
you know they said we're going to
sanction the russians and putin and his
uh group of oligarchs
even though you know every country has
all the cars the united states has
oligarch china has oligarchs the only
thing that has ever ruled the planet
were oligarchs so but the united states
uses the word like if the russians were
the only oligarchs on the planet
and it turns out that it says that um
you know that the russians probably
prepared for all this months in advance
so uh i don't know if some a lot of
those sanctions will have
uh the deep effect
that is um
you know that the press mentions
you know it might not have that deep
an effect on the russians especially
because they prepared in advance for a
lot of this stuff uh the russians also
talked to the chinese
and it's happened before by the way that
chinese could betray them
okay it's happened in the past in
history right but right now china and
russia probably have um incentives to
work together and so russia said we're
going to be dealing more with the east
and forget about the west okay and so
it's like you know um the west is going
to apply sanctions but in a way the west
is also shooting itself in the foot
because those sanctions are going to
work against a lot of companies in the
west as well and so keep that in mind
the fact that you uh apply sanctions and
say we're not going to deal with you
that means you have no commerce
you got to look for commerce elsewhere
okay so you know those are
double-edged swords
so one fellow says he says the reality
of it is simply that countries that rely
on american financial base will collapse
economically until they decide to
operate under the russian or chinese
financial base for me a person living in
africa the u.s collapse is no different
from getting a new phone europe and
north america will suffer the most the
rest of the world will dust off their
clothes and carry on
well i disagree
tremendously i'm saying if the united
states
economy collapses that's it for the
world okay
and uh people don't understand that they
think that they can live without the
united states that in fact it'd be great
if the united states collapses gets out
of the way this big guy so that they can
make some progress
i don't see it that way at all i'm
saying uh the united everybody's quaking
from the united states
just uh the punishment uh applied now to
russia it's gonna cause a lot of
headaches to
uh the russian
you know oligarchs right to the people
who rule russia
uh all these sanctions are gonna
hurt russia a lot it's gonna hurt europe
it's gonna hurt the united states but i
think it's gonna hurt russia quite a bit
and the only thing russia can do is go
east and deal with the chinese and that
might soften the blow but it's going to
hurt everybody what's happening maybe
not the chinese maybe they're the ones
who are going to really come out ahead
in all this because while the united
states will have big gas lines and
probably
problems with energy maybe you know
the chinese will use their all their
capital all the money they've saved up
and they're going to be buying countries
right now they're
the united states is worried that the
chinese are venturing into south america
which the united states considers it its
backyard and the chinese are strong uh
you know in in their push to get into
south america i know this from argentina
argentina you go now and you see lots
and lots of chinese
that they were never there before and so
yeah they're taking over the country
so
we got a new world new world order okay
another fellow says says there is a
cycle of everything empires are no
different empires are empires because of
the majority's confidence in them when
confidence is lost empires collapsed
totally in agreement the us economy is
the central economy of today's western
empire yeah it will be economics on the
periphery of this empire that will fall
first and the u.s empire will fall last
well i don't see it that way exactly but
it could happen the way he sees it here
i think
maybe it might happen that way but
my worry is that if if the us economy
happens to collapse regardless of
whether it's the first or the last of
the empire within the empire it doesn't
matter i'm saying that when the u.s
government collect
economy collapses it's it for for all of
us that's the end of it that's my
argument okay so uh
said the center will fall last as
periphery uh
economies collapse like uh what we are
seeing in europe that money will go to a
stronger economy which will prop it up
now uh there we disagree i don't think
uh
that uh
the united states will fall and another
empire will rise
china will never
be
uh
the number one empire i don't think
it'll ever make it there okay
so
in a way it's uh the more china grows it
gives unite and catches up with the
united states that's the amount of time
we have left to live here on this planet
that's the way i see it china will never
surpass the united states because the
united states will not allow that it
will create whatever it has to do false
flag you know whatever it needs to do
it'll create a war if that's what it
takes
the united states will stop the advance
of china militarily economically
whatever it takes it will stop it but
it's again shooting ourselves in the
foot because the united states depends
on china now
you know let's assume the united states
had the power to nuke completely all of
china without receiving a single bomb
back okay it just goes in there and
bombs the hell out of all of china kills
the 1.2 billion or whatever uh
inhabitants
it's the end of the united states
the united states depends right now on
china can't do that
you can't do that to china
right now the world is too much
interrelated to be able to do that kind
of action so everybody's got to be very
careful what they do now it's not a
question of saying oh we're gonna go in
there and uh and
kill all the uh people it doesn't work
that way the other one that people
should be aware of is that you know uh
the russians have um killer salar
satellites which i talked about a couple
weeks ago
and uh
if things get
really bad really bad you know
maybe the russians might start killing
some of the satellites
or all of them and if that happens well
we're all in trouble because all our
money is on the internet
and the internet and the missiles all
rely on on satellites
unless you're a flat earther then
then you've got another idea
okay uh phil says something about peak
oil here he says my study shows peak oil
predicted by professor mass to be around
the year 2000 60 years ago happened
around 2006.
okay so um peak oil happened 2006 and at
that point the civilization is running
its fastest at the cost of extracting
the energy it needs
uh becomes more expensive than the rest
of the economy can function now global
fossil fuels are said to be subsidized
at a rate of so and so okay a crisis has
been expected by educated studies since
the making of soylent green and mad max
okay we have known today would come for
some time
yeah um i don't think uh
piccolo has anything to do with anything
okay that's that's my take on that
extinction's gonna happen when we starve
to death and we we're going to start to
death not because of peak oil and we
can't produce enough energy or anything
related to that it's going to be because
the global economy is going to kill
collapse simply because commerce is
going to collapse simply because
you know we're not creating jobs
and
uh the proletariat out there all over
the world is uh
[Music]
uh making uh less and less
real money now you know the cost of
living everywhere has risen for
the
common uh wage earner
and uh some places you know it's even
below that standard some people can't
even make it to the end of the month
so
that's what's going to kill the economy
not the oil
yeah i don't think oil has anything to
do with it
or not not the primary thing it might
help
bring the whole thing down but the issue
here is that
it's going to be the global economy that
collapses not because of oil but because
we can't grow forever and if you can't
grow
you die that's the way it is in
economics
okay another fellow also talks about
that a decline of the fossil fuel
economics is um
economies i'm sorry is unavoidable any
nation willing to advance beyond that
must develop either nuclear or wind or
solar or hydro energies yeah that's true
i think there
a lot of countries are now moving into
recyclable energies right
there is no other way out okay and the
west has been very slow in that path i
don't know yeah they're working on it uh
as to the dependency of most developed
countries on the dollar or the euro many
countries have started to gravitate
towards the bank of china and crypto
yeah
that's true but uh the question is
whether china can replace the euro and
the dollar and
i'm not sure how many countries will
really go in that direction okay
we got to see that okay it's not an
unimaginable it's not unimaginable for
the following decades to see a large
change in the financial centers just as
it was for the year 2000 to see
manufacturing turn to the east banking
will also soon turn to the
uh east
um yeah i don't know uh i don't once
again i don't think china is going to
rise
never going to happen um i think the end
of the world will come before china ever
becomes the number one empire on planet
earth okay both militarily and
economically maybe economically it's got
a good chance but militarily that's a
different story altogether i don't think
the united states will allow it
you know when they see the chinese
rising they might do something about it
whatever
maybe even change the government over
there if they can okay but besides uh
china is also slowing down okay it's not
like china is uh
growing exponentially or anything like
that anymore you know china is also
having problems
okay i think the russians are a few
plays ahead here okay in that
the russian assumed the collapse of the
dollar is coming soon but the time
line is unknown and their
actions will just add another layer to
guarantee it happens so they are going
about their business as if the us is
irrelevant they will push ahead up until
a full-scale war is on the horizon and
will pull back not to start world war
iii
the risk is what will the military
industrial complex do
um
let me give you another scenario okay
and uh you know uh
russia has had many revolutions
that
at least the united states never had
okay
and here let me uh let me show you this
this is these are the revolutions that
uh
russia has had over the centuries let me
put it over here
okay uh you can see their uh timeline of
when they had uh revolutions that almost
overthrew the tsar
regime the tsarist regime and then you
know you had obviously the first russian
revolution 1905 these are the modern you
could say revolutions uh the second one
which was the kerensky revolution 1917
and then the third one which was uh
lening lenin's revolution then in
trotsky overthrew the
kerensky government and then they had
the civil war for six years okay
and uh yeah the civil war for
1917 to 1923 and then recently in 1988
to 1991
you had the breakup of the soviet union
which you could say
is a revolution a big upheaval over
there okay
and so uh here's a million dollar
question for you
is it possible that um
maybe putin is pushing a little too hard
maybe made a mistake in attacking
ukraine and then because
of that action
he falls inside in other words someone
overthrows the russian government
is that possible
i mean i want you to think that
the roman empire you know they had a lot
of conspiracies and when they saw weak
caesar
which is the word for that the
russians use xar means caesar okay
and
so here you had the caesars and they saw
the generals around them saw him as weak
they said hey i'm going to get this guy
out of here i'm going to be the caesar
and so the guy would overthrow the uh
the king the caesar and he would be now
the caesar and there were a lot of
palace crews
and murders and so on and you know
whenever
things aren't running well
the generals begin to whisper talk
conspire you know and i think uh there's
gotta be
many generals within the uh
within russia
that uh probably want to overthrow putin
and uh they're just waiting maybe for
their chance and maybe this is their
chance because suddenly you have people
on the streets you have a war that maybe
might drag on for weeks for all we know
and
uh you know and
then all these
[Music]
actions that the west has taken against
the economy of russia all this has has
to have an effect and maybe there are
some generals out there that are not
willing to
take all that and say hey why don't we
just get rid of putin and and uh
kiss and make up with the west get the
troops out of ukraine
and we're all friends again
i mean that's one possibility okay just
want you to think about that
anyway moving on to another subject okay
here we have seti
the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
and uh
here's a few a group of scientists
so-called scientists astronomers there
uh they were searching for aliens okay
and they use that array out there and
they use a lot of uh hours
uh with public money
and to look for extraterrestrial
intelligence
and sometimes i wonder you know maybe we
should look for uh intelligence
where these people work because i don't
think there's much intelligence there
and again i think uh
you know looking for aliens in the wrong
places that's what i call it it's highly
unlikely bordering on impossible to
detect another civilization and
it's known as fermi's paradox uh from
enrico fermi and uh fermi said you know
it's strange that no one has come and
visited us
and so
why haven't people come here why haven't
other civilizations come here haven't i
mean if it's like all these people
believe
that
there should be civilizations out there
much more advanced than ours
then why aren't those people why haven't
they traveled over here visited us or
conquered us or whatever
and so here's uh here's my take on that
let me take this out of here here's my
take on that okay
reasons for fermi's paradox why no one
has visited us why we can't
find
intelligence at cambridge or
outside of the earth okay
life can't travel interstellarly i
covered that the other couple of times
okay
uh we can't travel to the nearest star
never will never happened that'll never
happen it's impossible it's irrational
to think that we can travel to another
star okay that's the first thing
um civilizations are few and far apart
in space and time and very few people
ponder this
you know we've only had what 200 years
at most not even 200 years but let's
just be generous and say 200 years of
electricity of real electricity where
they started building things using
electricity
and maybe given another 100 years maybe
300 years right
uh the issue here is 300 years is a drop
of water in the ocean
of uh the cosmic ocean and of the
universe
i mean when you look at eternity out
there
what is 300 years nothing
and here's you have a planet like the
earth
and we've had you could say
[Music]
acquired consciousness
in electricity and all this kind of
stuff maybe 300 years now
and
this is it and we're going to become
extinct very soon
so that's it that's about the time frame
for any civilization similar to ours out
there maybe that's 300 years just
that's i'm going to go with that
assumption
and so it turns out that you know
another planet
develops and evolves you have all these
animals
eventually you have humans like us
intelligence develops there to our level
by the time they
are in the last 300 years of their
existence where they
discover things like magnetism
electricity and all this kind of good
stuff and develop technology to be able
to listen in
on other planets
the other planet is gone
because 300 years is nothing
you know in the in the
scheme of the cosmos
so
not only are we separated by distance
but we're separated by time
you know for two planets
that are close together that have
humans human level intelligence
about the same time it's almost
impossible
that's that's my take on that you it's i
don't know it might happen somewhere in
the universe maybe two planets which are
close together or something like that
very unlikely uh
life is a very scarce resource out there
and intelligent life of our level
intelligence of our level right uh it
takes a long time to develop
and it lasts very little a drop of water
maybe 300 years for that to happen in
two
planets which are close together
about the same time
almost impossible i'd say
and so that's my take on that and then a
small window of time in which human
level intelligence develops electric
electronic technology and shortly after
becomes extinct we're about to become
extinct so there's no chance for us to
really listen in on a very close
civilization that just happens to have
human level intelligence at the same
time that we do
uh
in the last 300 years of their existence
i don't think it's possible it's
the the odds are one in a trillion maybe
and super intelligent humans have the
highest level of intelligence that
mother nature can be queased
people say oh super intelligence out
there no such monster
no such monster we are the super
intelligence this is it it doesn't get
better than this if you don't have
intelligence well you gotta complain to
your mother you gotta sue her okay
but uh this is it this is all we get you
know we don't get any more intelligence
at what we have now if god
the devil mother nature father universe
came today and tried to explain to us
for example gravity or light or
magnetism
we all or pretty much a lot of us
have the ability to understand what
they're trying to tell us
what other super intelligence are you
expecting
some gadget
maybe go through the fourth dimension
even that we would be able to understand
if explained to us
there is no more intelligence than what
humans have and those people who say oh
no the super intelligence they've just
watched too many uh
hollywood movies you know matrix and so
on nonsense this is it
you don't even have your feet on the
ground you're flying in in the air
you know so now this what we have is
super intelligence
that's it doesn't get any better than
that mother nature cannot give us more
you know blessings
and yeah people
don't think that's possible
it's out of their
range of thought but yeah this is it you
don't get any more intelligence in what
we get now among humans this is the
highest level intelligence possible in
the entire universe okay
what other intelligence are you thinking
about please describe it for me so that
i can understand what this super
intelligence that you have in your tiny
little mind
that you're talking about what are you
talking about what is super intelligence
my god ufos aliens have never visited or
will ever visit earth okay
we can't travel to other stars no one
from any other star can travel here
and we're soon to become extinct so
that's gonna be the end of it nobody's
gonna ever even
know that we ever existed here on this
planet on this tiny planet here in this
side of the universe
so it just goes with uh and people say
bill you're not giving us much hope
[Laughter]
well uh i can either give you hope
and give you some false um you know hope
or
reality and i'm telling you reality
reality is that we're going to become
extinct very soon humans
and that's what happened to other humans
in other planets way before us
billions of billions of years before us
uh and big bang be damned
no the universe is eternal the universe
never had a beginning never had an end
and that has a lot of consequences i
want you to think about this because you
won't be able to sleep today if i tell
you
what i'm going to say next and that is
that
there never was
listen carefully there never was a first
human
in the universe
before us
there were other humans in another
planet
before that there were other humans
before them in some other planet in the
universe or in several places maybe and
before them there were others and before
them there were others and before there
were others
i don't know if that sank in
there was never a first human in the
universe the universe is eternal in both
directions of time
universe had never a beginning because
matter cannot turn into space
space cannot turn into matter therefore
the universe has always been there
and it had no beginning
and there always was some kind of human
see we always have this notion that
babies are born so that's when they were
created that you know when they came out
into the universe when they began to
exist
father nature doesn't understand that
mother i'm sorry mother nature or father
universe they don't understand that
they've been around
forever okay so i hope uh it gets you
thinking tonight
no first human ever okay
okay if we have a flat earther okay good
we have this flat earth he says we can
demonstrate the relationship between two
systems of
differing pressure if we have say a
vacuum system with a low pressure and a
system of higher pressure we know
through practical real world
demonstration people who rely on
experiments and they don't understand
anything
that those two systems require a barrier
between
yes when people
get conclusions from experiments and
they don't have the mental capacity to
analyze anything
so they say oh
i saw the experiment yeah it's the
interpretation that's uh what's missing
here okay if we do not have a barrier
between
we get equilibrium
uh taking effect
this is demonstrable uh fact that can be
shown over and over and this
understanding is applied to our everyday
uh lived practical lives
again all these people
they lack understanding of physics and
that's unfortunate for them okay because
they never make sense of anything and
they want to run experiments that's a
lot of flat earthers are very
experimentally oriented they think
experiments have something to do with
science
and how do you get it through them
that's you know experiments have nothing
at all to do with science we don't do
experiments in science we don't do
experiments in physics
we don't do math
in science we do not use math in physics
science is about rational explanations
not about doing experiments we don't we
don't do experiments we explain
experiments okay we have to explain the
cause the mechanism that's why we don't
do experiments and we don't use math
because math can only describe we have
no use for math in in science okay we
have to explain the mechanism that's
what science is about what the
mathematicians call philosophy that's
science okay
you have to explain the causes the
mechanism the efficiency of the
invisible stuff gravity magnetism light
you gotta explain
how that works how mother nature does
that all these magic tricks that we
can't see or or touch
okay
and so these people run experiments and
they say oh
i know something about vacuum that i can
separate a lower vacuum from higher
vacuum i need a
barrier in between that's the
logic i guess the illogic of this
flat earther okay so let's uh answer him
and uh what he's thinking about is a
vacuum in a chamber
he's not thinking of vacuum out there in
space
that's where the problem is
okay he thinks that because he does
something as an experiment he can
extrapolate what happens in a chamber
out there
to space that uh and you know that
surrounds the earth you can say it that
way i mean you know space doesn't
surround it but i guess you know what i
mean it's all that black stuff that's
around the earth okay and so the guy
says hold it you need a barrier because
if you don't have the barrier the thing
will even out
poor valo
okay so here it is we have to explain
why the water curves around the earth
why the air curves around the earth
and that's because every atom of air and
every atom of water is bound to every
atom of everything that's on the earth
in fact air
atoms are bound to air atoms on the
other side of the earth and water
atoms and molecules are bound to water
molecules on the other side of the earth
so everything tends towards the center
of the earth or somewhere in the center
where we have the center of gravity of
the earth because
the earth is a sphere and not a flat
disc like the heads of these people okay
and everything tends to the center
and so this and then what continues
after that uh
layer of first water and then air what
continues after that is
fewer and fewer particles you have
particles still quite a few particles
in fact
on the moon you have 10 to the minus 12
torr like i said and that means that you
have uh
particles per cubic centimeter
okay so it's not like there's no
particles at all you do have particles
uh in the
solar wind you have particles
even on the surface of the moon you know
there are particles out there but much
less than what we have here on earth
that's the issue and if you go between
two galaxies then you're probably
approaching you know zero particles
uh you know who knows what's out there
all we can do is calculate and say well
we think this is what it is maybe 10 to
the minus 19th torr but nobody knows
really okay what is between two galaxies
we don't have a a meter to go out there
and measure the uh
vacuum level between two galaxies but
that's as close as you're probably going
to get anywhere in the universe to
almost a perfect vacuum and i don't
think
probably anywhere there's a perfect
vacuum again remember the ropes
crisscross the entire universe and ropes
are not matter in the sense of being
atoms
but uh there's nothing
saying that there are no atoms between
two galaxies maybe there's some gas
there residual gas or whatever somewhere
or very very very very light gases out
there or maybe even loose atoms maybe
even neutrons you know
crisscrossing of ropes
so
uh
i don't know if there's any place on in
the universe where there's a perfect
vacuum maybe there is but for sure
within a solar system where there's so
much matter in comparison to between two
galaxies right in the solar system you
have planets you have uh gases you have
um
asteroids comets you got a lot of
garbage running around the sun
and
between every atom there's a rope
which is the background radiation that
they sense out there okay it's the all
these ropes that are
crisscrossing
in our vicinity that's what they're
measuring they call it the uh remnants
of the big bang
yes all these ropes are all around us
and they were able to sense that okay
and
i think that's all it is
and yeah so
in in the case of this fellow he says
you know
once you uh have a vacuum chamber you
need to separate
low from high vacuum yeah in a vacuum
chamber you do that i mean i work with
vacuum chambers you don't have to tell
me that you have to separate it in a
vacuum chamber it's different than the
earth
here in the earth you're talking about a
little planet around planet spherical
planet
and you have a gradient
a radial gradient
of uh first water liquids then gases
air nitrogen oxygen etc and then that
whittles down to you know the
it's a a gradient that ends up in this
almost perfect vacuum for our taste
which is minus 12 minus 13 torr
and
and that's that's how it that gradient
is is
radially distributed from the center of
the earth
that's what it is so this notion that
this poor fellow has that you know that
two levels of vacuum would even out
again it's what people have very
tiny minds and they
think that an experiment is going to
show them what's out there in outer
space and so they don't have the
capacity to visualize without doing any
experiment they need to go to the lab
and say i'm going to do an experiment
well do all the experiments you want but
you better come up with a rational
explanation what these people never come
up with is with an explanation for
gravity which is the subject we're going
to talk about next
okay
okay let's get on with gravity
um
oh i had one more issue there
sorry let me go with this one
it has to do with what we talked about
the other day axis
and fella just says why is the earth's
axis still
uh
neither access is fixed
how do you talk to these people what am
i supposed to do to talk to these people
they're not even listening
the the
the issue is that a one dimensional
one-dimensional one-dimensional
one-dimensional
axis
first doesn't exist
but
how do you conceptualize a
one-dimensional axis spinning
on its on its axis
can you imagine a one-dimensional axis
spinning
and uh
when you answer that question then maybe
i'll answer your question okay
yeah we have to put a three-dimensional
axis uh cylinder for you to understand
the concepts so that you understand the
definition
of spin
spin
the moon doesn't spin because its axis
rotates together with a moon that axis
cannot be a one-dimensional axis because
a one-dimensional axis cannot be
conceptualized
to spin so nobody ever figured out in
the religion of mathematics
that um
you know that uh
the issue of whether the axis spins or
it doesn't spin they just look the
distance and they say well the distance
of the surface with respect to the axis
but that's in mathematics okay in in in
rational
science and physics normal physics for
physicists okay you can't use the
mathematical one-dimensional axis
especially to talk about spin which is a
physical phenomena not a mathematical
phenomena okay
and so uh yeah you've got a you've got
to put a two-dimensional
three-dimensional axis two-dimensional
because you can explain it with that as
well not because of anything more than
that but with the three dimensional axes
a little cylinder
you can explain the notion of spin that
we have in physics and that is if the
axis three dimensional action not
one-dimensional three-dimensional axes
okay you can tell whether it's spinning
or not
and if it's spinning together with a
planet with a surface the the object the
celestial object in this case the moon
is not spinning on the other hand the
case of the earth
conceptually it says if it says if
it's as if
the
cylinder stands still and the surface of
the earth
twirls around
because now
every point on the surface is changing
its distance with different
points
on
the three dimensional axis you can't do
that with a one dimensional axis
okay
that's why the mathematicians never
discovered this because
when they use the one-dimensional axis
they could never tell or never even
considered pondered whether the axis
itself spins that's why people don't
know if the moon spins or not they say
well the moon spins why because it
rotates around the earth in 27 days so
what
what is spin define spin and then we'll
know
and i'm saying spin has in physics has
to do with
the axis standing still and the surface
moving with respect to a still axis the
earth spins so do other planets the moon
does not spin because the axis moves
together with the surface even when it
goes rotates once around the earth
and
we're not asking you to agree we're not
asking you to believe we're asking you
to understand please try to understand
before
before one of us dies
okay
okay let's move on to
let's move on to uh gravity what is
gravity what is this thing called
gravity this monster
well uh let me tell you uh here's a an
article that came out this week
and it has to do with black holes what
are mathematicians into black hole in
dark matter and dark energy that's all
they do these days
so uh
anyone who's outside of that today is
not a mathematical physicist okay so
here's uh went through the other side
give me a second here
so here we have
if i can get it up here
here we have uh
this
article that came out astronomers
discovered what's inside a black hole
for the first time ever
and what's inside says well it's
apparently a black hole is a hologram
that's what they discovered that's what
you're spending your money on you know
for these people to come out and say oh
it's a hologram
you know is this physics or what are
these people doing with public money
and here's the article this is what uh
they found in einstein's general
relativity theory there are no particles
there's just space time okay
in the standard model of particle
physics there's no gravity there's just
particles
connecting the two different theories is
a long-standing issue of in physics
okay so this is the starting point
and so they continue to say particle
theory is represented by one-dimensional
strings
one-dimensional strings what the hell is
a one-dimensional anything
sounds like a nothing i mean are they
again talking a 1d axis a 1d line the
mathematical line okay
now they're talking about they're not
even one-dimensional what they're
talking about is uh a verb they're
talking about motion of something along
an itinerary and they call that
itinerary a one-dimensional line because
that's what they represent it with even
though they put a two-dimensional line
to represent it with
because we can see the line and if we
can see it it's because it's got two
dimensions at least
okay it says researchers were able to
describe okay so they're not going to
explain they're going to describe
something mathematically obviously
what the gravity inside a black hole
looks like
okay so they're not going to explain the
mechanism they're just going to
describe mathematically that's what
they're going to be doing which is what
mathematics does
the inside of a black hole works off the
theory of gravity okay it is represented
in 3d space 3d space what the hell is 3d
space i thought space was nothing how
can space be 3d
if how can i have three
you know three dimensions if space is
absolutely nothing okay what is nothing
that which has no shape if it has no
shape it has no dimensions period we're
done
see how easy it was
all we have to do is define these words
and then we'll make sense but now they
say 3d space you know i don't have any
idea what they're talking about as space
times moves through it so here we have
space time which is a concept and moves
through 3d space which is nothing oh
that's great we have a concept moving
through nothing
makes a lot of sense
the surface of the black hole looks
two-dimensional again they introduced
the observer what what the observer sees
what he what it looks like to the
observer we don't do that in science in
science we do we kill the observer no
witnesses in science we don't care what
it looks like we cares what it is before
you look at it okay and surface is a
concept that belongs to
three-dimensional only exclusively never
to two-dimensional
this gives it a holographic look because
we do not see it as a 3d object again
talking about what people see and not
what the object is before you see it
okay this is because the theory of
particles does not work in three
dimensions
absolute nonsense poppycock idiocy
that's all that's all we read today in
the so-called scientific uh magazines
or
articles so none of that makes any sense
because they don't have the language
right they never defined these terms
and they're talking about 3d space
they're talking about the concept
space-time moving and
very scary stuff really
okay so what is gravity let's let's
begin uh by finding out
what this what the problem is okay
and so here's a rundown of it again it
fell into the other side
give me a second here let me put it back
up here here here we go
okay this is summary of gravity the
problems etc
we had 400 years of gravity at least i
would say you know since at least the
days of galileo
maybe newton even before then they
talked about gravity because they you
know like stebbins in holland he was
throwing
the uh balls
from
church from a
high uh church that was very up high he
was already checking the fact that one
ball falls at the same rate as another
one they all they both hit the
wooden board at the bottom at the same
time and he wrote about that it was in
um
1586.
so um
uh
1580 yeah 1586 i think it was and uh so
we're talking about people who were
already talking about gravity since
those days
and here we are 400 years later
a little more
and nobody can tell you anything about
gravity no one from mathematical physics
so these people study mathematical
physics they call themselves physicists
not a single one can tell you how
gravity works after 400 years
what do they need another 400 years is
that what we should give them 400 years
of
uh grants and money
okay is that what it's all about
metaphysics uh
mathematical physics uh oni uh describes
okay
all they have is descriptions
no explanation of the physical mechanism
of the clauses so you're never going to
find a an explanation for gravity
and today we're going to find out why
okay why they don't have any
explanations for gravity okay we have
two objects the earth and the moon okay
looney's alleged it is spinning
okay and
here you have uh the earth and the moon
okay
so we have two objects that's it that's
all you gotta explain
see how easy it was this is kindergarten
stuff
because it's not like uh you gotta
explain you know how
how a car works which is a lot more
complicated than this here you have two
objects two rocks essentially the moon
and the earth
and the moon does not fly out of the
solar system and we say that it is
because it is pulled by gravity towards
the earth what we need to explain is
what this gravity thingy is that
prevents the moon from flying out of the
solar system and again we have two two
rocks two
uh
celestial objects that's all we have
that's how simple the system is that you
have in front of you
okay so
this is very easy it should be
kindergarten stuff should be for babies
and here we are 400 years later since we
started this
at least
this inquiry this uh research this
investigation
and nobody can tell you why
uh the the earth uh prevents the moon
from flying away
okay
and then there's a couple more issues
there why doesn't the moon drift out of
the solar system that's one why is it
tidally locked with the earth
okay
how did the earth do that to the moon
from 380 000 kilometers away
here you have
uh tidal locking as it's called okay
and this is from the national ocean
service okay so it's official
and when the moon and the sun are
aligned
the waves here on earth are bigger and
when the moon and the sun are not
aligned the waves are smaller okay you
see what's happening there the little uh
uh
gif on the uh on the right there
and so
we have to answer that how does the
earth
uh or the moon in this case how does the
moon affect the earth from so far away
from 380 000 kilometers away what are
you gonna put between the earth and the
moon
that's the million dollar question
and so yeah
people want to do this with concepts and
they say well i'm going to put mass and
i'm going to put energy and i'm going to
put a force
none of those can explain the mechanism
we need in order to explain a mechanism
you need a physical object you need to
tell me what object lies between the
earth and the moon
without that you have nothing absolutely
nothing you can't use concepts such as
plasma you can't use vortex you can't
use any of the concepts invented by
mathematics you need to put a physical
object you can put a dog if you want in
there you can put a tree a rock but you
cannot put mass you cannot put energy
you cannot put field
okay that's the issue
so um yeah tidal locking you gotta
explain why why is it that uh the moon
affects the earth and the earth the moon
from 380 000 kilometers away one from
the other
can you explain it
without putting ghosts in goblins i mean
you know if you're going to put ghosts
in there yeah of course
okay so here we have it uh
why doesn't the uh sun fling both
celestial objects you know the earth and
the moon out of the solar system
i mean you know here you have the sun is
twirling the uh earth around itself
right
apparently and you can't see anything
between the earth and the moon
probably if you go there you can't touch
anything there
the question is there something there
that's the million dollar question
and if you say there's nothing there
you're doing black magic
period we're done
you're doing black magic you can't say
that there is nothing there because when
you say that there's nothing there or a
concept such as field or energy or mass
then you're doing black magic
now you need to put a physical object
something that binds the earth to the
moon something that binds the earth to
the sun etcetera and the moon also to
the sun by the way
so they have to be bound they have to be
interconnected somehow physically
interconnected otherwise you're using uh
black magic
that's that's the question that we have
in front of us
no mathematicians at any university on
the planet can explain the cause
in a rational manner they have a couple
out there okay
and one of them is this fellow uh victor
toth who we talked about uh
for the last week
and
he says the fine he says whether we
think of gravity as geometry or as
potential field doesn't really matter
the equations are the same the numbers
tell the same story either way
yeah maybe the numbers tell
whatever we don't care about that we
want to have the mechanism what is the
mechanism
why doesn't the how does gravity work
that's what people want to know
they want to understand that
says the geometry in question is the
geometry of space time
geometry of space time
space time is a concept what do you mean
geometry of a concept
sounds like the geometry of the 1d axis
you know there's nothing there
you see all these people do geometry
with with abstract concepts
you can do it with a with an object such
as a square
or a cube
ideal or otherwise doesn't matter
because you have a shape in front of you
but 1d 0d 4d
doesn't work
those are not objects there's no object
that is 1d 0d or 4d
that's how simple it is you know it's
got to have shape okay and yeah if uh
introduce all these what mathematical
objects
then then you get you run into trouble
because then you can't make sense of the
universe so you can't use mathematical
objects and
introduce them as if they were physical
objects objects of physics
the only part of the
of that geometry that has a noticeable
impact is the part governing time
the geometry of time
the stronger the gravitational field the
slower clocks tick
what's that got to do with geometry
the geometry of time what are these
people talking about you're talking
about nonsense that's what it is
as to how it works yeah that's what we
want to know how it works the principle
of least action
okay i never heard of a mechanism like
that but let's find out the action is a
mathematical quantity
that's what it is okay so the principle
of list least action you say okay what
is that is the it's a quantity it's a
number
and so
again it's
it just shows you that these people are
not even on the right page okay
they're not doing physics
and yeah here you have it
uh he confirms this with what he says
next and i think in a different uh
paper he says some believe that we are
clever enough to eventually figure this
out
so here he confirms that you know nobody
knows anything about gravity but someday
someone will figure it out maybe okay
so that's what we're investing money in
we're investing these people
investigating
uh gravity and they're doing numbers
they call them geometry geometry of time
and uh and then
the question is whether
that's going to give you the answer that
you're looking for which is how does
gravity work what is the mechanism
so these people are researching
something that does not answer the
question that people ask people say how
does it work and these people say here's
the numbers
it's a geometry of time
yeah
okay uh so here here's a rundown of what
we need to answer okay and again
we have this uh
astronaut he falls to earth again we're
gonna deal with two objects when instead
of the moon and the uh earth we're gonna
deal with the astronaut and the earth
two objects two things okay this is what
we gotta answer why does that guy fall
to earth
he's he tends to fall to the center of
the earth to be more exact right okay so
the question is we have to answer this
how does one object attract another why
doesn't that astronaut fall out of the
solar system why does he go the other
direction especially if
if he's
falling towards the earth and the earth
is being swung around the earth the sun
that astronaut should be going in the
opposite direction you know just do it
with a little ball you know
revolve a ball around yourself right
here it is
very simple
you should have centrifugal
uh
force on the ball okay
you know when you do like this if i let
go
this thing starts flying out
so here's the sun twirling
the uh earth
around itself the earth orbits you know
the sun
uh you know
pretty big speed because if we travel 30
kilometers per second we're going around
the sun like if we're being swung and
here's this astronaut trying to get to
the earth he's being
he's going towards the earth while the
earth is going around the sun why does
he fly out
why is he falling towards the earth when
he should be pushed outwards
well you say gravity well yeah it's
gravity but what is gravity
again are you going to put what are you
going to put between the astronaut and
the earth are you going to put
nothing are you guys put a concept like
uh energy field
mass
is that what you got time
is that what you're going to put between
the astronaut and the earth
is that how you're going to explain the
mechanism using the word time
geometry of time
okay so
this is how some people
answer the question okay
and they say well god
pushes the astronaut down he
he just
makes the astronaut fall to earth
okay that's one explanation i guess
again hopefully god grabs a hold of him
instead of doing it from remote control
because we would not understand the
mechanism if god does it from afar he
would be doing black magic right
so god probably does something else
maybe he just sends uh
one of his angels okay and so the angel
takes the
astronaut downwards okay that could
happen
but at least now we have a mechanism
the only thing i don't understand why
would the angel have wings
you know if uh he can't flap them out
there in outer space okay
no air to you know
push against but at least uh there is
contact between the angel and the
astronaut okay we understand that okay
so maybe that's one mechanism it
involves a little bit of magic there
because we don't understand how the
angel is coming down to earth i mean he
can go in any direction or you know
you gotta explain how how the angel
flies
we can understand how a bird flies but
an angel in space
a little difficult
okay that's one explanation that you can
find out there i guess some people would
answer that way here's another one uh
people use and say force
the force may the horse be will he
so uh we have this force pushing the uh
astronaut downwards but force is a
concept so you can't say that the force
pushed or pulled on the astronaut you
can't use the word force to explain
gravity because that's a mathematical
concept we're talking about mechanisms
here
what is the mechanism of gravity what
underlies gravity how would you explain
it to your 10 year old kid that's the
question
and
here you get the idea of what really
happens as far as uh
gravity is concerned uh using the word
force and that's this notion that
you know that we have that we have this
equation okay force equals to the
gravitational constant g
mass 1 mass 2 over distance squared okay
okay great that just tells us the only
thing you should keep in mind here is
that
you know according to mathematical
physics mass is equal to weight and the
reason there is no difference the reason
they are synonyms perfect synonyms is
that they never were able to isolate
mass from weight okay because the way we
determine mass is by weighing
whether you do it on the moon or here on
earth okay we so we have no definition
for the word mass that is different than
the
for the word weight okay
uh they can define it in one way but
then
the way they figure it out is by
weighing you know things
and
the other thing you should keep in mind
weight is location specific you have a
different weight
at different locations
or the astronaut in this case above the
earth okay so if you just take one
millimeter step forward you'll have a
different weight
okay and people don't understand that
that's an important concept because that
means that weight is location specific
you move your location you have a
different weight all together
okay you weigh one gram more one gram
gram less depending on which direction
you move okay
and so we have to answer these questions
these are part of the
uh
notion the mechanism of gravity okay we
it's it's involved with gravity okay
so we can't just say calculation force
we need to explain the force the cause
of the force the mechanism that
underlies the force
okay here's another version this is the
one from general relativity and it's the
astronaut falls because somehow
uh
we have this warp space time a concept
which they uh uh illustrate with a uh
fishnet okay
so somehow the astronaut falls because
of this fishnet okay and uh apparently
though
uh earth weighs down the fishnet okay
and so this astronaut has no choice but
to slide or roll
down the fishnet okay that's the idea
but uh once they explain it that way
then they deny it at the end of the show
and they say oh by the way you know you
weren't supposed to take it uh
literally you know they say um
that oh you were paying attention to the
uh
fishnet uh or the canvas analogy
yeah
i was paying attention because i was
looking at the mechanism they said well
you're wasting your time here's the
equation
i don't want any equation i want the
mechanism i want to do physics not math
and they don't understand that they
think that math is physics and that's
the end of that okay and that's because
they've equated math with physics when
that's not the case physics something
else physics is tell me the mechanism
and you have to explain the mechanism of
why the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system and so they say okay it's
warped space time okay great
warp space time yeah so the sun weighs
down the canvas
fishnet
whatever
this fabric
and the earth rolled around the
depression like a ball around the
roulette okay we all understand the
mechanism no problem
so then you say okay so you're saying
that there is a physical object that
comes against
the surface of the earth because the
earth slides or rolls around this
depression
this wall
and they say you're not supposed to take
the analogy so literally
i'm trying to explain why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
don't tell me i'm taking the analogy
too literally when you are giving me
that explanation you're saying that the
reason the earth doesn't fly out of the
solar system is it rolls around slides
around
a depression the walls of a depression
caused by the sun weighing down space
time what is it that i don't understand
what are you saying that if you give me
that analogy which i understand
perfectly why then do you take it out
later on say oh by the way don't pay
attention to the analogy
i need to explain why the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system
so don't tell me not to take it
literally of course i'm going to take it
literally
uh
physics had better be literal and
physics means that you literal means
that you should be able to illustrate
the mechanism
and if you illustrate a canvas i'm gonna
take it literally yes okay in other
words the analogy is okay
but then you can't say oh but that's
just an analogy you got to look at the
math i don't care about your man
yeah i'm going to look at the analogy
and if your analogy you know it's fine i
mean you can bring a mock-up
of your whole theory to the conference
that's fine no problem but then don't
tell me oh don't pay attention to the
mock-up because i just used it to
illustrate well if you illustrate it
that is your mechanism that is your
theory of gravity
don't tell me later on not to take it
seriously
that's the issue they contradict
themselves
and that's why it's irrational
okay uh here we have um
another version this is the particle
verse and the ether version okay
what you're seeing all those dots that's
known as the ether bunch of particles
and so they say okay we have all these
particles
okay and the question is if we have all
these particles
why does the what's the mecha i still i
don't understand the mechanism of why
that astronaut is falling to earth
because of all those particles in the
background
i mean are the particles pushing him
down how about the particles that push
him away
you know and so they they devised a
couple of um of explanations for the
particle hypothesis here
and let me go over these two main ones
okay here's one
okay and uh
it goes like this uh
they say you know that if um
what is called a
negative momentum transfer in other
words if you throw a ball at someone you
know it should push them away
but they claim that when you throw the
ball at someone the ball pushes pulls
him inwards to you you say how can that
possibly be and they say well they do is
change the sign in the equation and
suddenly the motion is not a way but
towards you
that's it that's what it amounts to in a
nutshell
that's john baez guy who said all this
his site on uh what is it riverside
university uc riverside
okay so this is known as a negative
momentum transfer
that's one way which is
uh
so realistic
because what they're saying is that you
know again i throw the ball at you
and instead of
knocking you farther out it brings you
towards me like if you were
uh pulled by i don't know a spring or
whatever
makes no sense whatsoever
in
physics but they say it makes a lot of
sense in mathematics okay
fine and here's the other version it's
known as you could call it it's got
several names casimir effect the sage
effect here it is it's got all these
uh people who reinvented year after year
even to this day they every time they
someone comes around and says oh i
discovered something new what did you
discover i discovered what is known
today is the lesage effect and that is
you know you have all these particles
all over us
in front of us and behind us and if you
remove the ones in front of us you know
what you have is a shadow effect where
you have particles from the outside
pushing you together in this case you
know uh
fellow with is uh towards the uh donkey
and all these people lucretius nine uh
really around 60
65 60 bc
fascio uh he was patio uh he was a
right-hand man of newton
uh
then the sage
kramer
radicare casimir cassiemir did it not
with gravity he did it with
electromagnetism but the mechanism is
the same the idea is that you remove the
particles between and the particles from
the outside push in
so this is the other particle mechanism
that people have come up with there
could be others i'm just giving you the
most the two most prominent ones okay
but the issue is
no one has ever been able to explain
gravity with particles
and in fact we have um
here's lucius by the way he uh
you should read his book the rare natura
the nature of things
and
uh so he's a myriad primary particles
moving in many
directions and he ends up saying of the
earth does not load down the air anymore
then limbs are freight it is the weights
that come from the outside of ourselves
that um
that
go
when placed upon us that god when placed
upon us
in other words um he was saying that you
have all these particles of uh
of whatever out there
uh adams i guess he meant because he he
was a atomist from democritus
and uh so he believed that you know that
gravity essentially was all these
particles that are pushing down on you
you know and you essentially
are uh serving as a mask
as a shadow for something else
so you have all these levels all these
layers and all these people
every
year they you come up with all these new
people who say oh i discovered something
new oh what did you discover well i
discovered that gravity is a shadow
effect
and that's been going on for you know
thousands of years now 2000 years at
least
yeah you can't explain it with particles
and here's a man who proved it okay for
those of you who are interested in
showing
that uh particles cannot explain gravity
at all so you should never use particles
otherwise you'll
be
uh passing for
ridicule okay here it is his name was
kant emmanuel kant and he did a full
study on this you should read his book
okay
and so what does he say he says i'll
just go
real quick because i got a couple of
these why only these two forces why only
repulsion and attraction
because they are the only ones that are
thinkable
and it turns out that the quantum
mechanics they came up uh with four
forces
they have a
push-pull and maybe
and perhaps
okay so they have four forces
and
despite that i guess they'd never read
the kant okay
then you have when this action of a
distance occurs without a the mediation
of matter lying between the two portions
of matter it is called
unmediated action at a distance
one of the problems that kant had and a
lot of his contemporaries and that's
what we inherited today is that these
people could not imagine here were two
objects
the earth and the astronaut the earth
and the moon doesn't really matter two
objects
and one attracts the other especially
you know if they're massive like the
earth
and the question is how does it do it
and they say well there's nothing
between them i don't see anything i
can't touch anything there so there's
nothing there
that was a bad conclusion
because when they said there's nothing
there they didn't realize they were
introducing black magic
at that point in time
if you don't put something there and you
talk about action at a distance remote
control
then what you're doing is introducing
black magic
and you can't use concepts okay you
can't say
rey you can't say wave you can't say
field you can't say energy you can't say
mass you can't say time you can't use
any of those words to explain the
mechanism the mechanism needs requires
something physical
something uh that's physical and
first you gotta define what physical is
hopefully it has nothing to do with c or
touch
okay c or touch are the wrong criteria
irrational criteria really uh to define
the word
object thing okay no you have to define
thing
uh in a different way and we define it
as that which has shape
so whatever mediator you have there it
has shape but it cannot be seen or
touched that's the whole thing okay
okay and
here we have um kant also he says he
continues the book has quite a bit of
passages that you should really read
because uh
it's uh quite involved it's the
metaphysics uh his book on metaphysical
mechanisms of nature okay 1786
and he says the difference is merely the
basic uh attractive force doesn't offer
itself so immediately to our senses
again they were looking at seed touch
they were looking at a witness they were
looking at
observer and they said you know we can
all imagine push
pressure because it surfaced against
surface we all pretty much understand
that when a ball comes up against
another ball or your hands against the
box
but
how do you conceptualize pull when you
don't see the mediator that's where the
problem is and so he says uh
it doesn't offer itself so immediately
to our senses as impenetrability in
other words the repelling force the push
force we all understand it's the push
pull force that we have trouble with
because again he says it it's not uh
you know amenable to our senses
uh doesn't giving us concepts of
determined objects in space because it's
not felt but only inferred
okay so this was the whole problem okay
the attractive force gives the
impression of being not a basic force
but a derived one meaning that you need
push to
derive pull that's what he was saying
here as though repulsion were the upshot
of a hidden play of more basic moving
forces and he said earlier there's only
two forces push and pull so he's saying
that pull
uh
was derived or inferred from push
that you need two push forces to explain
pull
okay so people who are interested in the
subject should read him i only took
snippets okay from his book
and here's the last one okay
and again he says the most common
objection to unmediated action at a
distance is the claim that a portion of
matter can't directly act at a place if
it isn't there okay so if you have
nothing there how are you going to
explain pull
but when the earth directly influences
the moon to come closer it is acting
unmediatedly
on a thing thousands of miles away and
the space between the earth and the moon
might as well be regarded as entirely
empty because even if there is matter
there it has no effect on the attraction
again since he could not see feel or
whatever touch
uh the mediator of gravity he said
there's nothing there
and so he says it's an unmediated force
that's that was his conclusion
but at the same time he says you need a
mediator for pull for attraction
and so he was kind of on a
path of contradiction only because he
tried to run an experiment he tried to
observe he could not see
what was there between the earth and the
moon so he concluded there was nothing
there and the only way he could explain
it if there is something there well then
all that space between the earth and the
moon had to be filled with objects and
he was thinking of c touch objects not
of that which has shape
okay
and so he says the web thread
misunderstanding of this matter is a
result of confusing the mathematical
context of regions of space with their
physical contact through repelling
forces
but even such an apparent attraction
must deep down involve true attraction
true attraction meaning genuine meaning
not made of push meaning true pull okay
because the portions of matter whose
pressure or impact is at work wouldn't
even be matter if they didn't have
attractive forces so the attempt to get
rid of true attraction you know genuine
pull and explain all phenomena of
approach in terms of apparent attraction
meaning with push right moves in a
circle
okay so he was smart enough to figure
out that you cannot explain pull with
push but that's uh what all these uh
poses today came up with they came out
with push gravity
okay push gravity
and they they want to explain it through
again the two mechanism primarily those
two mechanisms that are uh the casimir
effect in other words remove particles
from the from between and the ones from
the outside push them together that
mechanism which is a shadow gravity
mechanism you could say the sage
mechanism lucretius
mechanism all these mechanisms are the
same mechanism essentially they're
saying you know you remove particles
here or you have pushed particles from
there and uh something blocks it and and
that creates you know a differential
from one object to another that's that's
the way they explain it
and the other one is uh the negative
momentum transfer which is absolutely
ridiculous they say we just change the
sign on the equation put a negative sign
instead of motion outwards we have
motion inwards
oh yeah no kid do it in the lab
you want to do observation you want to
do experiments do it in alarm okay prove
to us that your equation works in the
lab
okay not on paper
okay
so here we have uh this gentleman his
name is richard muller and he tells us
what we need to explain about gravity
this you should pay attention to because
he puts
the finger right on the problem right
there
so this anyone who wants to deal with
the word gravity
has to look at these two issues number
one and number two he says so for
example if you have the earth there's a
big mass here and you have you with your
little mass here every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you should repeat that ten times to
yourself every atom on earth is pulling
on every atom of you to understand what
he's saying
for every atom on earth to pull on every
atom of you they have to be physically
connected
there's no other way
okay i don't care what you put in there
you can put a rod you can put a steel
beam
uh you know a
string a thread a rope a chain you got
to put something there
okay
and you can't do it with concepts such
as energy field mass none of those
charge you know none of those
it says you're also pulling on it the
amazing thing about gravity is that it
goes right through things
so you have to explain those two things
why every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of you and vice versa and why
gravity goes right through things those
are the two things any person dealing
with gravity has to explain if you have
not explained those two things you know
nothing about gravity just that simple
okay so those are the two issues any
person
who wants to explain gravity has to
explain
the mechanisms of how you can achieve
those two
results okay every atom on earth pulling
out every atom of you you pulling on
every atom of the earth
one and the other one that gravity goes
right through things right through the
wall
go through walls through water through
air goes through everything
gravity goes through everything how does
it do that
okay and again it's the only way there's
only one way
and that is all atoms are physically
interconnected then you can explain that
you can explain those two questions
those two issues you can explain why
gravity goes through things
because they're all connected and why
every atom of you is pulling on every
atom of the earth and vice versa
only if every atom is physically
connected
there's no other way
okay
and again you're gonna have to explain
the mechanism that
there you have the two questions you
gotta answer
okay so uh here we have the moon again
okay and it's going around the earth and
so the question is you have two objects
and what did mueller say well he says
every atom of the moon is connected to
every atom of the earth okay
and gravity goes right through both
objects
okay so it's looks like every atom of
one ad of the moon is connected to every
atom of the earth
and so let's illustrate what mr mueller
says he's a phd in
mathematical physics but he's got the
right questions
and here we have it okay so there you
have it you see why
every atom on earth is connected to
every atom of the moon i didn't draw
every atom obviously
but now you can see why the moon doesn't
fly out of the solar system because
every atom of one object is
interconnected or connected to every
atom of the other object okay so the
earth uh
swings the uh moon around itself just
like the sun uh swings the uh earth
around itself and so on so now we can
understand why the moon doesn't fly out
of the solar system we don't need any
space time we don't need any
negative momentum transfer none of that
nonsense we don't need um what is it
particles
we cannot explain it with discrete
particles we can't use the word force
just say oh the force be with you yeah
great i mean we don't have a mechanism
by using the word force
so here you have what we
um
we we can answer uh richard muller's
issues and we answer both of them why uh
every atom of one object is connected to
the other to every atom of the other
object and why gravity goes right
through
things everything no one can have a
shield protecting himself
against uh gravity
okay so that's the bottom line
and here we have um just in case you say
well bill
uh
you're a nobody uh let's go with
somebody okay let me give you somebody
here's brian green and he says the same
thing
that i just said okay here it is
he says um that
the moon
is connected like if it were connected
by a rope
to uh
the earth okay you can see the rope
there coming up okay
that's how they explain gravity that's
what they
that's what they sense is happening but
then they try to explain it you know or
describe it really mathematically and
one person
on quora wrote this it says in space
gravity is the tether okay
yes gravity is the tether
very important word there that's what
the
brian green is illustrating there
just because it isn't a physical object
does not mean it doesn't exist again the
tether is real it is a physical object
but we can't see or touch it and that's
why they think there's no physical
object there but if they remove the
physical object they're doing
gravity with um you know with black
magic
there is a gravitational tether between
the earth and the moon yes momentum
keeps the moon from moving forward like
the athletes imparting spin to the
hammer while gravity keeps it from
flying off in a straight line which it
would do just like the hammer if gravity
suddenly disappeared
which it won't because it is a
fundamental force of the universe there
is also a gravitational tether between
the earth and the moon system and the
sun and between the solar system and the
center of the galaxy
exactly so there you have it that's what
it's all about there is a tether there
and that the tether had better be you
know connecting interconnecting every
atom of those two objects
that's the story of gravity in a
nutshell very easy baby stuff once you
see
the connections the physical connection
yeah that's so stupid that's so easy
and now these people say 400 years now
what's studying this stuff and they say
well it's warped space time it's
particles it's the force the force be
with you you know
and uh and they have all these
mathematical
descriptions
followed by irrational explanations you
know warp space time you mean warp time
is that what keeps the earth from flying
out you're not supposed to take the
analogy literally that's that's what the
answer okay
so uh why does a spoon fall to the floor
okay you let go of the spoon here you
have a spoon okay i'm gonna let go of it
it falls to the table let me do it again
repeatable experiment just in case for
those of you who
uh say that's part of science we let go
of the spoon
and you see it doesn't fall to the sky
it always falls downwards
and here's why
okay you have the spoon
and you let go of it
and of course once we see the ropes that
connect every atom of the spoon to every
atom on earth i didn't draw them all by
the way
then you can see why the spoon falls
downwards and not upwards are there
ropes connecting the spoon to the moon
of course and there are ropes connecting
the spoon to the air that surrounds our
planet of course there are atoms out
there but where are most of the great
majority of atoms which are close by
well they're in the direction of the
center of the earth that's why okay
they're not in the direction of the moon
they're not in the direction of the sky
they're not in direction of the
air that surrounds our planet no they
are in the direction of the center of
the earth that's why the earth is
spherical round right
and it explains why the air and the
water also curve around our planet
okay
any questions
yeah
you had better connect every atom you
should connect the dots and then you'll
be nobody will hurt you okay then it's
easy to understand gravity but as long
as you use mathematical concepts such as
field and energy and charge and mass and
huna and time you know
wave
you know then you won't you'll never
understand you'll never understand
gravity and that's the situation today
in mathematical physics we've had 400
years of mathematical physics not one
mathematical physicist mathematician
can explain gravity to you in a rational
manner
okay let's get on with some of the
questions and
in fact the first one common question uh
has to do with what we just discussed
okay a fellow says he says
are cosmic strings cracks in the
universe pbs space-time he says there's
uh this video there and i went to see it
and he says cosmic strings
uh which are under tension have
vibrations traveling around the speed of
light can pass right straight uh through
each other
it sounds super familiar as follows says
in other words he's referring to the
rope
he's saying that the electromagnetic
rope which is our proposal right
um
looks like
what these people who do strings that's
what they're describing
and the only clarification i'm gonna
make there is that uh the
strings are one-dimensional
okay
and so they're not referring to the same
strings we have but the important thing
is as you're gonna see in a second here
um
they talk about strings going through
strings
it turns out people want to beat me up
and say bill how do you mean the rope
goes through the rope
and you hear these people say the string
goes through the string and nobody
questions that
so next time someone says how do ropes
go through ropes i'm going to say
go talk to the string theorists because
they say the same thing and somebody's
got to question them so please ask them
first how do strings go through strings
if they're physical
right and if they're mathematical then
they haven't explained anything okay
they're just saying that a concept went
through another concept
i do that all the time you know concept
going through concepts very easy to do
okay so so i went to this site it's a
meadow down okay
and this fellow uh runs this site okay
uh a pbs spacetime
and so this is what he explains in the
video and he says are cosmic strings
cracks in the universe where do quantum
fields come into all of this well it
turns out that the universe is a
gigantic ice cube
so uh you know we had a
big bang which was extreme heat and now
we have this ice cube
we're all solid stiff i guess right no
motion
to understand cosmic strings and to
convince you that they probably do exist
so he's he's not going to explain to you
he's not going to try to convince and
persuade and try to recruit you that's
what he's going to try to do
so it's interesting that he uses that
that language he says convince you
he's going to convince you that he's
right that you should believe
anyway it says they have the subatomic
thickness
meaning 1d
that's what he means by subatomic
thickness because the thickness of a
string is known to be one dimensional
according to mathematical physics and
that's no thickness at all so it doesn't
have subatomic thickness it has no
thickness at all like all lines in
mathematical physics
but prodigious mass
so it's got a lot of mass but it's got
no thickness and they last through space
at the close to the speed of light
man sounds like he's talking about a
ghost you know no thickness
1d right
lots of mass and travels at the speed of
light
i thought einstein said that if you have
mass you can't travel at the speed of
light
and that's why they say close to the
speed of light because if they put it at
the speed of light they'd be violating
special relativity
it says they could be the most bizarre
undiscovered entities that probably
actually exist
probably actually exist right okay maybe
yeah
if they exist uh please show us the
mechanism how do they go through each
other
for example right and here he talks
about that he says
keep heating plasma this is how they're
going to make these
strings
uh closed-loop strings
keep heating plasma until you hit
temperatures of the extremely early
universe meaning very high temperatures
right and a phase transition occurs in
the quantum fields
that underlie all particles so they're
essentially going to heat up the fields
and what is the field i'm going to put
that down there it says field a quantity
represented by a number that has a value
for each point in space and time
so field is a concept it's more
specifically it's a number actually it's
a bunch of numbers
and what they're going to be talking
about here is about freezing heating up
you know putting temperature to fields
having fields move
they're going to do all this magic with
this concept with these numbers okay so
keep in mind that when he whenever he
mentions the word field he's going to be
talking about a bunch of numbers that's
all it is
and he says we we would think uh i'm
sorry says a field's inherent
temperature massively changes its
behavior
how can a bunch of numbers have
temperature
okay that's the first problem they said
we should think of the higgs which is
the particle of mass if you can
understand that
as a fifth fundamental force because it
arises from the same
field structure as the other non-gravity
forces
so uh
he's going to get a noble because he
says that
we had four forces in quantum mechanics
right
what is it the electromagnetic we have
the gravitational we have um the gluon
and we have the the weak force and now
he's invented the fifth force
may the force go with you it's the higgs
he says the this particle of mass is the
fifth force
okay it says uh it's the freezing of
this field they're going to freeze the
field remember it's an ice cube the
universe that can give us or that can
give us our cosmic strings okay a
quantum field is just some numerical
property that the fabric of space can
have
okay so he's saying that a field is a
number confirming the definition that we
have down there that's all the field is
but he says this field has temperature
okay and he's going to move it around
he's going to freeze it he's going to do
all these things to this field and so
just a bunch of numbers what's he going
to do put the number 5 in his freezer is
that is that how he's going to freeze it
anyways the field at any point can
oscillate so now the field is going to
vibrate back and forth up and down okay
going to oscillate around that value and
those oscillations have what quantized
energy states
okay
these vibrations can move through space
so now he's going to move these
vibrations
these uh
field vibrations okay and then he says
we see them as particles so it's all
absolute rubbish nonsense that his
entire language is ridiculous has no
place in science whatsoever
okay all of it is should be trashed
none of it has anything to do with
science or with anything okay
okay so uh here's where he says that
strings go through each other that
nobody questions okay when they say that
everybody just says oh okay that sounds
right
okay here it is it says cosmic strings
move and vibrate okay
now remember there are one dimensional
wet fields
that have temperature and then they move
and they vibrate okay
they're also under pretty insane tension
tension yeah we can understand tension
on the rope because it's a rope
3d
okay no problem there but these guys
talk about one-dimensional
strings and they say they're under
tension okay
this inevitably leads to collisions
between segments of strings either two
distinct strings or two sections of the
same string
when this happens either the two
segments pass through each other pass
through each other
uh nobody questions that
what do you mean they pass through each
other how can strings pass through each
other why doesn't anyone question that
why does everybody try to be up and say
bill how do your ropes go through each
other
and i'm saying well
from now i'm going to say just go ask
matt o'dowd he should know because he's
saying the same thing he's saying the
strings go through each other
see how easy it is
if a straight string collides with
itself it can cut out a loop if the loop
intersects with itself again it forms
two smaller loops they do all kinds of
stuff with this stuff with
they break them apart they put them
together they sew them
they knit them
whatever
one-dimensional strings move vibrate
have temperature the whole works
and that's what they're studying by the
way all all your money because a lot of
these are public funds most of it is
and this is what they're researching
strings
one dimensional strings okay
okay another fellow says something along
these lines he says uh cosmology
astrophysic has gone insane okay
due to a continuous century-long failure
to predict the technological discoveries
the standard model theories indicated
should be found i don't know if it's got
to do with technology it's got nothing
to do with technology science does not
have anything to do with technology but
then he says well he goes through other
things there he says then they had best
start looking into plasma physics for
answers
well no plasma physics there's no such
monster because plasma is a concept and
we don't do concept physics we do object
physics okay physics only with objects
never with concepts plasma is a concept
it's a concept that means that something
is happening to the atoms
ionize in this case and so you can't
talk about a process as being a physical
object
plasma is a process it's not a
standalone object you can't see plasma
in a single snapshot
you need to watch a movie to understand
what plasma is okay so try to explain
plasma to a uh
klingon
an et
and he's going to say uh what is this
plasma thing that you're talking about
and you say well it's all these atoms
that are losing their electrons in this
soup of electrons and uh
ionized atoms
that's a
known as a process something is
happening
a happening is not a standalone object
plasma is not a thing
it's a concept and as such there is no
such thing as plasma physics okay no
such monster
not in science at least
so no uh it's what the electric universe
does
uh who are the electric universe uh
electric universe are people who have
never defined the word electric they
have no idea they uh confess that they
have no definition for the word
electricity but they use that anyways
and call themselves the electric
universe
okay and uh final issue here fal says
how do you falsify the theory of
interconnected atoms magnetic fields as
a source of increasing velocity of stars
is the magnetic field of the sun
speeding up the orbital speed of the
planets in our solar system etc etc
uh
in science we don't falsify anything
it's illegal to falsify okay so we don't
falsify i guess he's thinking about
popper that's where he got his education
karl popper who said that uh theory
should be falsifiable
and the question to mr popper is
um
falsified in in the mind of who
the pope the dalai lama who who
who are you going to falsify it to who
are you going to persuade convince
convert and recruit
okay so we don't falsify anything
because falsify is a question of belief
belief has to do with religion not with
science
and then i don't know where you got the
idea the magnetic field source of
increasing velocity of stars
uh
i don't know where he got that
uh i never said that by the way okay i'm
not saying that the uh magnetic field uh
makes a star go faster or slower no
absolutely not i'm saying that a galaxy
rotates not because uh not because of
dark matter that's on the outside
supposedly which is what i talked about
last time
star that's on the outside goes faster
than the one on the inside or at the
same speed why because they're all
connected so the galaxy rotates as a
single platform think of a uh
carousel
merry-go-round right
the outside goes just as fast as the
inside
that's what a galaxy is
the
galactic magnetic field just uh
preserves the or helps uh maintain the
integrity of the whole galaxy and that
explains why stars on the edge or any
star for that matter doesn't fly out of
the galaxy because they're all bound
just like the planets are bound to the
sun just like the moon is bound to the
earth
and with that i'll see you on wednesday
bye